sí muy buenas tardes para ti de
principios tales como tú has dicho hay
expectativas sobre todo porque en este
momento el consejero del órgano comicial
se encuentran reunidos para lo que sería
un próximo informe en las próximas horas
acá donde se ha establecido este centro
de cómputo al llegar a la expectativa
porque mientras que aquí se va a decidir
quién será el contendor del candidato
andrés araus en las inmediaciones de
este centro se encuentran reunidos
concentrados seguidores del candidato ya
q pérez quienes han decidido esperar
aquí han dicho que defenderán votos a
voto hasta conocer el resultado final
hasta el momento el 97 82 por ciento de
los votos escrutados y avanzar un
proceso ya es muy lento pero por qué
sucede esto hace algunos minutos también
podemos escuchar las declaraciones del
consejero josé cabrera y él dice que
bueno todavía faltan muchos muchas actas
por traer a la zona de los cómputos son
básicamente actas que se encuentran en
zonas de difícil acceso que debe primero
acercarse y posteriormente a tener todas
estas actas hay un proceso de
totalización hay un proceso de
impugnación hay un proceso
apelación posteriormente el tribunal
contencioso electoral deberá certificar
que no quedan recursos pendientes con
ninguna de las actas para luego de
finalizar todo este proceso dar un
informe definitivo al país gustavo que
se espera para el día de hoy en la
agenda de los candidatos y también una
vez sea nombrado ese esa dupla que va a
disputar esa segunda vuelta entonces
cómo van a ser la conformación de los
votos quien le dará votos a quien como
podría ser el escenario de cara a esa
segunda vuelta
pero básicamente esa es la expectativa
que se mantiene también el país lo
seguro es que va haber una segunda
vuelta electoral como va a ser con
solamente dos binomios electorales como
lo reza el código de la democracia en
este país cuando se realizará en 45 días
como establece también la norma
electoral se realizará el 11 abrir ahora
cómo van a hacer esas alianzas es lo que
se espera ninguno de los candidatos ha
dicho con quién va a negociar esa
segunda vuelta electoral por su parte
marlon santi quien representante del
movimiento político pachakutik aseguran
que ellos pelearán contra la derecha de
igual forma y leonidas iza que era uno
de los candidatos del movimiento
político que decidió declinar su
candidatura hubo ciertas divisiones que
bueno luego apoyaron al candidato y ya q
pérez aseguraron también que pelearán
contra la derecha así que no se
esperaría una asociación entre los
señores guillermo lasso si ya q pérez
podría suceder con las que izquierda es
democrática que va subiendo en la
totalización de los resultados santiago
gustavo muchas gracias por este reporte
desde la ciudad
de quito y muy atentos a cualquier
pronunciamiento allí en el cn en la
capital ecuatoriana